In this problem, an adult male weighs
160 lb and consumes 0.5 gall per day of
drinking water and 0.02 lb per day of
fish. A pollutant is present in surface
water at a concentration of 0.02 mg per
liter. The pollutant has a cancer slope
factor of 0.02
2 mg over kg * day to the minus1 and a
bio concentration factor of 15 L per kg.
Assuming exposure occurs through both
drinking water and fish ingestion,
estimate the excess lifetime cancer
risk.
So in this problem, let's just start by
searching for a keyword if we don't know
where to begin.
So if we take the cancer slope factor
and search for that in the reference
manual, this will take us to page 144
where several cancer risk equations are
provided depending on the exposure
pathway. Since the problem mentions fish
ingestion, we will use the equation at
the bottom that includes the FI* BCF
term.
The equation here is CW = B W * LRF
over
CSF
* the quantity of IIR plus
FI
time
B CF.
Now let's define each variable in the
equation
and convert any units that we need to at
the same time.
CW is the chemical concentration in
water in millig per liter. This is given
in the problem as 0.02.
BW is body weight in kilog. The problem
gives us body weight in pounds. So let's
convert 160 lb to kg.
LRF is the excess lifetime cancer risk
factor. This term is unitless and this
is what we are solving for. CSF is the
cancer slope factor with units of mg
over kg* days with the entire quantity
to the minus1.
This is given as 0.02.
IR is the ingestion rate associated with
water exposure in liters per day. Here
it represents drinking water consumption
which is 0.5 gall per day converted to L
per day.
Note that these unit conversions are
available in the reference manual.
FI is the fraction ingested which is
unitless. Importantly in this problem FI
is not a mass or a volume by itself. In
this case we will substitute the term
here with the amount of fish consumed
times the bio concentration factor. This
will represent the fish exposure
normalized to the water intake. And our
units will show that this makes sense to
do. That's the best I know how to
understand this part of the problem. But
if you understand what's happening here
better than me, please feel free to drop
a comment.
Now that we've defined all these terms,
let's plug them into the equation.
So we said CW = 0.02
mg per liter
times the body weight of 72.6
6 kilogram
times the LRF that we are looking for
over
the cancer slope factor of 0.02 02
* mg
over kilogram day
to the minus one
times the ingestion rate for water of 1
lers per day
plus the quantity here of
Oh, I should probably
calculate these two separate from each
other so that there's no confusion.
This is going to be
0.009
kilograms per day.
times the bio concentration factor of
L per kilogram.
At this point, all of our terms are
defined and we can see that the
ingestion terms combine correctly. The
units cancel properly and the LRF comes
out to be unitless exactly as is
specified in the reference manual.
So we can see that kilograms and
kilograms cancel here. Liters per day
will sum with liters per day.
There are no liters on the top over
here, but liters is present in the other
side of the equation.
There are no other milligrams in the
problem apart from one on one side and
one on the other.
And
kilograms here will cancel with these
and day will cancel with these because
of the minus one here.
So simplifying this down we can see that
LRF
will equal
1.1 * 10 -5 as a unitless value.
So that will be the lifetime cancer risk
factor which is our third answer over
here.
So this is an almost ideal type of PE
problem in my opinion and this is
because excluding
the slightly confusing part that's going
on over here related to the fish
consumption which I probably didn't
explain very well. All this problem
requires is for you to do the following
and it's going to be one find the
correct keyword in the reference manual
based on what the problem is asking.
two, select the best equation that you
can find
from wherever the reference manual leads
you.
And then three, just convert all of your
units and plug in your numbers.
And again, if anyone has a better
explanation for why the term FI gets
replaced with the water consumption rate
here, please feel free to explain in the
comments. Thanks.